[Music]
definitely get mayhem in the more i mean
i i you guys know that i don't actually
pedal books
i don't sell anything that i don't truly
think is good i think if you want to
play the smith war you should definitely
get mark's book
it's um it's sort of the gold standard i
don't even have it but i know
so many people who
uh who basically swear by it so
um i think that a lot of people ask me
sort of what book should i get i don't
think you need more than 10 or 15 books
if you want to build a really good chess
library for yourself you don't need to
spend more than
you know let's say 25 per book
if you want to spend like 250 bucks
you can build for yourself an amazing
chess library a couple of opening books
a couple of books on chess instruction
and that's that
1921 okay
a serious opponent mexum
poland
all right well
let's see how the smith mora holds up at
this level
thank you gleason for the five subs
appreciate it
all right so so far we've yeah everybody
seems to be accepting the smith mora
so far everybody's accepted it including
this guy e6 yeah and this has been the
most popular setup it's also kind of the
most annoying setup and the one that i
know least about
um in my day
d6 was considered
sort of deregur
but now everybody's going d6 so does
anybody remember how we should position
our pieces here what should be the next
move and this move again
i repeat can be counter intuitive if you
don't know and play the more it can seem
like it just
violates the rules of development bishop
c4 but as i've explained
on several occasions this bishop is not
as bad as it looks it can support a
potential knight sacrifice on d5
and in general if the e6 pawn collapses
this bishop is going to be very nicely
poised
to wreak havoc in black's king potential
energy is a great way to understand it
a6
so now if i remember correctly the move
is castles
now we continue our development by
castling and b5 this is one of many many
viable systems for black clearly he
knows
um
what he's doing
okay so bishop e3 it's too early to
sacrifice i think this is still theory
this is about where my knowledge ends so
we're going to be on our own
from here on out and hopefully our
opponent is as well
how to conceptualize this position well
knight d5 is honestly one of white's
main ideas just
shoving this knight onto the center
and sacrificing it in order to get rid
of the sixth one and of course open the
e
file bishop b7 we could develop the dark
square bishop to f4
and and try to clamp down on the d on
the d6 square
okay that's one option
but knight t5 appeals to me because
black's entire kingside is undeveloped
and it seems to me that we have this
opportunity to create
you know to create an initiative in the
center
and so now seems to be the best time at
least intuitively for knight d5 and we
can play this move largely without
calculation because we know that in the
event that the sacrifice is captured
we're going to have tremendous play down
the e-file so i'm very confident that
taking the knight is not a good idea
here
and this uh kind of shows you that you
don't always have to calculate every
sacrifice
you know for 20 minutes some sacrifices
are so typical
and so powerful that you you can kind of
intuitively judge that that they'll work
out if they're accepted
well if it backfires it backfires but
there's no guarantee
but i don't think black should capture
it
i think black's best move is probably
just to play d6 and to continue
developing but that's not an easy move
to play even for you know someone at our
opponent's level
what what's the point of the night being
there well the knights in this first of
all the knights in the center which
means it's bothering it it's disrupting
black's development making it a little
bit hard for black to coordinate
the other there are a couple of ideas
that stem from the knight's placement on
d5 and you know the more familiar you
are with the position the more of these
ideas you know for example bishop e3
bishop b6
is one concept and that sets up a fork
on c7
another idea is to play bishop g5 and
then you can kind of see how the knight
and the bishop combine to control a lot
of these squares
and you know we're just putting a lot of
pressure on black's position
yeah and finally our opponent is settled
into a think
it's important to understand that in
these kinds of positions very often
it's not like there's anything super
immediate i mean there are immediate
ideas like bishop e3 which should be six
as i just illustrated
but a lot of the uh you know to play
these positions well you often have to
play for the long term pressure right
it's not all about what happens in the
next two moves
you know you have to be more patient
than that if our opponent plays
well black's lack of development is
making it difficult for black to sort of
coordinate
and obviously it's
reducing the likelihood that
accepting the sacrifice leads anywhere
good
it's just a hard position to play
right it's just a difficult position for
black to play and that is reflected in
his thinking time
how good was bishop d5 i don't like
bishop d5 as much i don't feel like the
bishop
is exerting the same kind of pressure
that the knight is so that bishop could
have just been ignored knight ge7 okay
that's interesting and kind of
encouraging for us
so
first of all the king is boxed in
there's no no squares for the king so
that's something to just note down
we don't have to act on it necessarily
that's just something to note
to note in our mind
so let's go through the ideas and and
weigh the pros and cons of them
my instinct here is to develop the dark
squared bishop because it's our only
minor piece that's not developed now
where can we develop it too
well we can develop it to g5 that's one
option just pinning the knight and
creating even more pressure on black's
position that looks pretty good bishop
g5 looks great actually
another option
is to play bishop f4
and to threaten the fork on c7
and that would essentially force black
to play rook c8
but i'm not sure that the bishop on f4
is that well placed i don't really see
what it's doing other than threatening
knight c7 check
and yet another idea is to play bishop
e3
and revert to our old idea bishop b3
bishop b6
so
bishop e3 has one drawback which is that
it closes the e file and
it increases the likelihood that e takes
d5
is now going to work out for black i
still think after e takes d5 we have a
huge initiative
and massive compensation but we would
ideally want to be able to put a rook on
you one without having to move our
bishop again
i'm kind of leaning toward either bishop
g5 or bishop e3 i hope i've made my
considerations clear
i hope i've made my considerations clear
so bishop g5 is the more long-term move
whereas bishop e3 is the move that you
play you know if you want to challenge
him in the short term
hmm
bishop g5 though my one concern
with bishop g5
is that it doesn't create a threat
i know that sounds i know i just said
that it's not all about creating threats
here but bishop g5
let's say black plays d6 or rook c8
i feel like black can start
consolidating a little bit
and we're going to have a hard time in
some of these positions creating threats
on the other hand
if bishop g5 f6 happens
then we have a potential bishop
sacrifice on f6 which could be really
really interesting
so honestly i think both moves are fine
it's just a matter of taste and we'll
check with the computer afterward
let's go for the long term
let's go bishop g5 i think most of you
are more excited about this move than
about bishop e3 and okay we'll go bishop
g5
probably in a game i would go bishop b3
for the record i i pro i kind of prefer
bishop b3 but
this uh is more principled i think in a
certain way thank you this below i'm
very curious how our opponent is going
to defend here yeah obviously h6 bishop
h4 g5 blunders made on f6 so we should
be aware of that even bishop f6 is an
option in some of these positions no
queen b8 doesn't solve all of black's
problems queen va we can drop the bishop
back to f4 for example
and that's a lot more problematic than
bishop f4 on the previous move it's
really not that simple for black to make
to play here black has to be very
skilled in order to not lose this
quickly h6
well um okay bishop h4 let's hope for g5
why is g5 back because knight f6 is
checkmate look at how the king is boxed
in that would be a smothered mate
you might say well why is knight f6 not
checkmate right now the g7 pawn because
it captures diagonally is protecting
that square currently
so
in the meantime as our opponent is
thinking
let's come up with a couple of potential
ways that we can improve our position
right and it almost seems weird to talk
about that since our knight is just
sitting there on d5 but it's just
chilling right we don't need to move
that knight black is nowhere near
completing his development
so
i can see a couple of possibilities we
can definitely oh my god
no way
i i honestly that is unbelievable
oh man that's really anticlimactic too
that's crazy but that's just what
happens when you put a lot of pressure
on your opponent
oh my god you guys called it i i was not
expecting this
this is an anti-profit move
jesus
collapsed under pressure
well
we can still analyze this game
so let's see so this is i mean this is
all theory e6 a6 b5
bishop b3
yeah tons of games in opening explore
bishop b7 now
apparently the move is queen e2 95 might
have been premature here
and the one game which reached this
position in the database
continued knight a5 and i actually see
two games in the database
one of them on bishop g5 bishop b7
97 97 queen d6
knight b3 abf6 so which game was this
this game was
let's see
2 000 against 25 40. so the 2540 was
black and eventually consolidated and
one here
that was one game
and then another game continued bishop
f4 ed5 bishop d5 wow
and that is a 2280 against the 2150 and
he also lost jesus
so maybe knight d5 is premature if only
we had esserman in the chat
i'm assuming 95 a good practical choice
even though it was objectively sound but
i don't think it wasn't objectively
sound like the sacrifice itself is sound
it just might be
uh
unsounding the sense that
knight a5 could be a strong response so
what happens exactly after he takes d5
sure i can i can show the line so 85bd5
why is this bad for black how do i know
that well i'm seeing two things in
particular the first is that rookie one
is coming and the second is that the
pawn is going to advance to d6 and it's
going to pick off whichever piece
appears on e7
for instance um
what you know what do you guys what
occurs to you here for black what's it
yeah knight a5 for example right okay
it's a rookie one check
again it doesn't matter what black
covers with bishop e7 will go d6 and
very important such positions to
understand this is a super important
insight
you're not going it's important not to
rush with d take c7 like if black
doesn't move the king for example we can
keep that pawn on d6 what that does is
that paralyzes black completely whoops
sorry
what that does is that paralyzes black
completely
and makes it impossible for black to
develop their knight because of rook
takes c7 check
for example it's not yeah no but it's
not just a trade you're going for
checkmate here you're threatening 95
you're threatening knight g5
black is totally busted and paralyzed
here i don't know if that makes sense
but it might might be the case that
black and somehow survives this survive
this with some computer moves
and that's why sacrifices are a uniquely
human very often a uniquely human
decision
these are some of the hardest positions
to play from a practical standpoint
so we'll check with the engine but i can
bet you a silver dollar that like ed585
is at least not bad for white
so instead knight ge7
and again i was leaning toward bishop e3
but i was slightly concerned
that in this version the fact that the
bishop is blocking the e-file is going
to buy black
some
sometime
for example d6 although probably even
even this is good
d6
knight b3 b3 probably black and survival
of the computer moves yeah but by
survive it i don't mean black wins
probably black can somehow equalize with
computer moves
you know but look at this position like
is this a position that you want to play
with black
you know is this is this something that
you
that you would want to go for
and
you know that's why computer evaluations
are are often
you know
completely beside the point no queen b3
is also fine yeah queen b3 is also i
just wanted to keep the d6 pawn
protected by the queen that was my
instinct
but
yeah i don't know if this makes
intuitive sense that these positions are
are are really really difficult
computer says white is crushing of black
takes now you see so
it's not even defensible from a computer
standpoint because of the overwhelming
nature of
white's attack we played bishop g5
yeah and obviously i mean g5 is
ridiculous
i was most concerned about just
something simple like d6
and then i was contemplating a move like
rook c1 just sort of improving the
position
now you can play rook e1 and you just
sort of accumulate the pressure and make
it very very hard for black to move
and these positions are hard to play for
both sides
from white standpoint it's often hard to
figure out how do you continue improving
while
making sure that he takes d5
you know that you're keeping tabs on the
possibility that your opponent accepts
the sacrifice at the most inconvenient
moment for example here
after ed585 knight e5 might already be
quite a nasty defensive move because it
forces a bunch of traits
a knight e5 de5 but even this looks
really really uh
sketchy for black
a rookie five
rooksy one queen c1 i don't know i don't
know what to make of this
um but this might be a little bit more
defensible for black so the main
takeaway from this game apart from the
theoretical question of whether we
played knight d5 correctly
is that
you often want to aim for positions that
are difficult for your opponent to play
rather than just
parroting the engine assessment
that's why the smithmore is such a good
opening because it's not the engine's
favorite but it presents a host of
practical difficulties for black even at
the highest level which is why
grandmasters often don't accept it
now we can look with a computer
um we played knight d5
okay so knight g7 actually is correct
according to the engine at a relatively
low depth it's correct
wow and bishop g5 is correct
yeah so ed
ed is just really really bad for black
you can see it's plus two
bishop g5
so i wonder bishop e3 oh bishop e3
knight takes c5 e takes d5 and knight a5
that's another really important
technique
where
oh don't yeah exactly
that's another very important technique
where you don't take the the knight with
a pawn you take it with a knight and the
reason for that is that you want to keep
your pawn shell intact so that your king
is safe right you don't want to open up
the e file
and here white's initiative fizzles out
um
so bishop e3 was wrong we played
correctly
h6 bishop h20 so our opponent played
well but you can see that the engine at
first was giving a big advantage now
it's sort of giving a smaller advantage
for black and d6 is correct
basically what we were discussing d6
rookie one and now
it seems like ed black can get away with
edd knight a5
knight d4 still looks very scary g5
black has defined
a move which may seem obvious
when you see it with the engine but oh
my god queen d7 and then black should
castle queen side
and even this position i argue
is far from you know
maybe even practically i would prefer
white here because knight takes d5
there's a there's a pin on f5
black cannot afford to open the a file
so black has to go b4 now we go queen d2
and pick up the pawn
and you can see the computer line is
bishop g7
queen takes b4
and now
knight takes d5
queen a5 bishop d4 here here already
black is consolidating but
um
this is all computer chess like g5 and
then queen d7 and realize that you
should castle queenside and then a4 b4
so
when you analyze with the engine in
these situations it creates the illusion
that the defense is actually quite
simple but
that could not be further from the truth
that's what i really want to emphasize
to everybody
it's fine to analyze with an engine but
try to weigh the position from a
practical standpoint and ask yourself if
you'd like to actually be black here or
in a comparable position
yeah rook c1 was not suggested
yeah we were looking at rook c1 but here
already black can take on d5 and this is
not a good version because
you're not in time to get your rook to
e1
no this is how you should analyze the
computer you should just have these two
perspectives in mind on the one hand you
should always strive to find the best
move on the other hand you should try to
try to have a sense of you know the
practical worth of something
um
what human doesn't play rook c1 after a
long castle oh and that line we just
looked at now rook c1 is not tempting to
me actually because it actually sends
the black king
to b8 to me a4 is very tempting that's a
very typical
uh typical concept in such positions
especially when there's a loose knight
on a5 you want to open up the a file to
exploit that weak knight
rook c1 is a is a classic case of one
movitis where you
you think oh i'm going to get my rook to
get square but you're in reality you're
helping black
why not roxy want to be four castles
well that's a good question why not
rooks you want to hear
well here the problem is knight takes b3
let's say queen takes b3 and bishop g7
and black completes his development and
consolidates although it's very close
knight c6
takes takes queen c7
rook d1 and bishop e5
and white's position starts to fizzle
out
yeah crazy
and if a takes b3
then black can probably just take this
pawn
no but more i would argue that it's not
too advanced for your elo i think if you
just sort of
which move in particular were you or are
you confused about
if i may push back on what you just said
a little bit but look at how the engine
actually shifts this assessment here
bishop c2 actually now is good for white
no castles
and once again we get a very so we don't
know this is what we're what we were
analyzing previously a4 before
it's just as confusing for me like i
also don't really understand the point
of half of these moves for black
yeah but
i just don't like i don't i don't love
the the idea i feel like it's a limited
you know mindset
when when you just sort of see a move
and you kind of say ah i would never
understand that move this is way above
my level
that can be true in some cases but it's
usually every move can be understood
but i was sort of explain but but was my
explanation confusing for you the
concept that the knight puts pressure on
this on the position and that capturing
it opens up the e file which gives white
an attack that's basically all there is
to it
but if you knew the typical ideas in
this position you absolutely would play
it right if you played this line for a
couple of months and you knew that this
was a very typical move in such case and
you understood it you would play it
right it's not true that you wouldn't
play it
um maybe if you don't play this line
then
you can't expect yourself to know this
idea
but once you understand that the
reasoning behind it you should be able
to play
okay
and that's that unfortunately yeah this
is quite anticlimactic but it is what it
is
okay our first win over 1900.
all right guys
um
i think this is a good spot to call it a
day it's it's three in the morning i
should probably go to bed
this was a short game but nonetheless
of course with one more win we'll hit
1800
so it's very tempting
[Music]